we want the researcher to really
thinking about how far they can push
technology how far they can push the
stay of VR and so this is why we
encourage people to take a risk and we
even go as far to tell them if you think
too much about technology most likely
you will make a too small staff and
that's not good enough for research
because if the most thing we do are
incremental then I think is that you
have failed its purpose you're listening
to the Microsoft Research podcast a show
that brings you closer to the cutting
edge of technology research and the
scientists behind it I'm your host
Gretchen using in 1998 Microsoft
Research opened a small lab in Beijing
to expand its research efforts and draw
on the immense high-tech talent pool in
China no one expected that only 20 years
later
MSR Asia would become the dynamic
organization it is today with innovative
research contributing to nearly every
part of Microsoft's business dr. Shah
when Han has watched it grow from the
beginning and this year celebrates the
labs 20th anniversary as Managing
Director corporate vice president and
chairman of Microsoft's asia-pacific R&D
group on today's podcast dr. Han gives
us a brief history of MS our Asia from
its humble beginnings to its significant
role in the AI boom today talks about
MSR Asia's unique talent pipeline shares
his vision for the complementary roles
of machine intelligence and human wisdom
and explains why he believes the more
progress we make an AI the better we
understand ourselves that and much more
on this episode of the Microsoft
Research podcast
[Music]
selwyn hon welcome to the podcast today
it's great to have you in person in the
studio all the way from China Thank You
Gretchen these nights will be you see
the corporate vice president of
Microsoft a chairman of Microsoft's
asia-pacific R&D group and the managing
director of Microsoft Research Asia what
has inspired you to do the work you do
and to take on this giant set of tasks I
actually think I have the best job in
Microsoft in the world
the reason is every day when I wake up I
will explore the future possibility I
would do this experiment that experiment
tried this idea tried that idea
I do know not all of them we walk
actually many of them will fail I mean
that's the nature of the game because
you really try to explore the unknown
but this really the process and I
understand people like to get a cool
reason they want to get all they want to
really have impact and the results are
even we all for that but I think the
feeling of every day you wake up you
know you will explore something new and
then someone even pay you to do those
kind of work and a lot of times even
encourage you to take more risk to think
bigger to add you to more risky project
that plus a self is so enjoyable see
you've been with Microsoft for a really
long time you started in 1995 yes and
that's not long after Bill Gates started
Microsoft Research in 1991 were you with
the research organization when you
started yes what was the vision for a
research division in general then and
how have you seen the enterprise writ
large evolved over the years since
you've been there if you actually go
back to a 1991 Microsoft still compared
to today is a tiny company but even
though Michael so already in the young
software industry is already the
undisputed leader and I think it's
really beautiful sight the we do you
need me to continue move less stay off
VR on the technology landscape in
general software area so I think he set
up near Mesa he won the future computer
can
can understand humans language can
actually recognize objet understand the
war can do the conversation and I think
at that time I mean if you remember
there's a to AI winter that's really the
first winter and so I think it's really
a very card sea and the full side of
Bill to entry style the research I
remember when I join the MSR we have
less than 40 people and today we go to
the size of thousand people of course
micros also call aloud I think the whole
industry also call Allah so I think
certainly it's a good journey so then
the research division was here yes and
you were here yes so that's like my
organization today in China Michael so
associatia the reason we have my coastal
research Asia is because we want to
expand the company we want to expand the
MSR so I remember when I joined I think
Greek our big boss in MSR and Bill has a
conversation and then we immediately
know we cannot just have to research
them in u.s. yeah because we know we
want hire enough and also we don't
believe all the small and the most
passion people doing research we all
come to us through Microsoft so we pay
to go to where they are
this is why we start international
expansion and then the 97 we did our
Europe lab in Cambridge in 98 we agitate
the China lab in the engine cific area
and then the racing history I think the
key is at that time no one thing we are
even close or willing to invest to etch
it to those kind of AI technology
development or research so this is why I
think we should really very very
thankful to those four sides also the
willingness to actually invest
primeira behind it even though we all
know it would take a long time you and I
take a pill popular thing you take a
morning 20-30 years I don't think he
will protect we really have the AI boom
today and then today you just cannot
escape a day we saw any AI news or
activity I so I think people thought
about that but at that time people think
about science fiction right and then the
reason they call AI winter
very few people want to invest here
including government right and
interestingly too I think most research
institutions embedded in industry were
applied research as opposed to let's let
some scientific minds have some free
rein here and really think out for that
long time yes you are supposed to right
and I think that the company is there to
make money
so typically most company can only
invest on something more shortened basis
which is actually writing and I think
university government funding agency can
do very long-term research that's how
our society works and I think bill I
think that he recognized the industry
and then also company when they are
successful they need to participate in
building this so-called stay off the our
advance the state of the art technology
because the very simple look at the
high-tech or I think it is because of
fundamental technology got at events so
the pipe they build become bigger and
bigger people can build the beta
application so in return they had all
these are positive feedback cycle so
every company will benefit and I think
this is why when we build the MSR the
suite commission was defined they
clearly the first one is advanced they
of yeah and that's really it's just
similar to academic research happening
in university you also encourage the
researcher to actually publish all they
have done and then share with the whole
war that's really a very important
aspect because in all the science and
engineering advancement in our history
we always talk about you stay on the
shoulder of the giant everyone can look
further so I think it's very important
for industry for company commercial
company to participate in this
state-of-the-art building and then the
second mission of course is called
technology transfer because of course my
croissant to benefit from all the great
research result we have done to improve
our product so that will make our pod
are more competitive and then the third
one
is incubation which also extremely
important in our industry because the
breakthrough really happened in the much
much fast pace there any other industry
so Microsoft will want to make sure we
always stay on top of that and then an
elevator way to do that is to invest and
also to invent the future and I think
the incubation becomes a third part of
our core mission let's talk about
Microsoft Research Asia
it's celebrating a milestone anniversary
this year 20 years in China let's talk a
little bit about the expectations for
MSR Asia
20 years ago and why you believe this
particular lab of MSR has been good for
Microsoft good for China and actually
even good for the world so 20 years ago
the reason we go to China it's because
we want to expand MSR and then we know
China has a huge number raw talent on
top of that I take the stem attract a
lot of the young kid to study those area
so 20 years ago our first I would say
milestone really come from the mission
we set up like first mission at the
mainstay of yeah I think to a large
extent we can to be a big power to the
effort to bring China to the world-class
research in then scheme I think really
the first significant paper published in
the world-class journal or conference do
really come from our collaboration walk
with the university faculty and students
but 20 years ago do you do the first
breakthrough right from zero to the
landscape I think we contribute a big
part to that effort and then we
certainly feel very proud of and also
not just that not just really tech to
the landscape and particular you
mentioned how this is good for the world
I think in terms of the academic
exchange and interaction between China
and the US by large big
we're on us-based company and they get
to develop their partnership with the
University faculty student and now again
the China represent the in terms of the
graduate student in us is the biggest
source right and also the interaction
between the top university in u.s. top
university in China now it's almost on
the day to day basis and I think we also
feel very honored to actually play a big
role to make this as known today and I
think we all know particularly in the
science and engineering the water
innovation the more global collaboration
interaction a good thing for maybe one
and they're talking about the microcell
of course we benefit founded right
almost all major Microsoft Prada all
over the year until today all have the
MSI a contribution and then on the
incubation pod we also have several
technology inside micro so I'll totally
started and all the responsible by MSI
to where to start ever
that's an amazing track record for 20
years
anywhere on the planet that's just
amazing and so much of it comes from the
talent that you get talk about MSRs
particular approach to the talent
pipeline you talk about incubation you
talk about your internship and you talk
about your training tell us about that
yes we always say you might go saw our
biggest essay is people write and in
research it's actually more so how do
you generate the best research we saw
hire the best talent and in China it's a
little bit different when we went to
China 20 years ago they don't really
have established researcher in computer
science for too high almost so so we
need to really help to faster the future
talent for computer science research so
this is why from day one we know we need
to engage with university to help to
bring up the students to prepare them
for the future computer science research
even here today we have a very very
distinct internship program typical when
people think about intern is for people
to walk in just summer three maybe four
months in the lab
in our internship we always had all year
long internship program one of the
reason we can do that is many of our
senior researcher including myself we
take professorship in the top university
in China because of that we actually
take on the PhD student that means after
the student finished the course war they
will spend two or even three years with
us to actually do their PhD what
supervisor by us so we actually have an
intern work in our lab for a long time
and the number is also my bargaining we
actually more intern than the four-time
employee
our ratio is about one point five to one
in terms of intent to employee ratio so
the talent faster is always a big part
of our operation and I think of course
that intentional a lot of good we saw so
it's about three years ago we decided to
do MSI an online network so today we
have an online network at more than
5,000 people of course a big part of
them our intern and then because unique
the timing and also the way we do these
things it's also totally coincide with
the developer China IT industry okay and
then you look at the number we have ten
plus alumni which act at the CX all
mostly our CTO for the big public
trading IT company and then on the
academic frong
we have 30 plus professor now
established professor in the Chinese
university we also have the 50 plus
founder for the startup in China and
then five of them already which the
Unicom status so it's actually for so
many influential people coming out of
one organization in China or even the
whole world pub is unheard of so I think
truly is a win-win-win situation for
Microsoft for industry for China and I
think just like today just like the
diversity inclusion area you got to take
a broader view not just for yourself
because we will only improve or make the
to progress if the entire
ecosystem entire platform has the lye
mix and representative of the telling
you want right whether it's diversity
whether it's the best research Tala if
you don't take this view I don't think
you will call very far let's talk about
the unique focus of Microsoft Research
Asia so I guess I can answer this
question in the sort of philosophical
way I know people one could resolve I
think the micros also without treatment
company and also it's easy to report
when you actually have a good result and
make a good story in the press all right
but the real day to day work in research
doesn't really happen that way if the
research you say well the reason I do
part a because I think a Padre can
generate the query resolve so I can
carry war I would say this is a puppy
already or wrong thing to think about
I think the right thing to think about
is we are organization we encourage
people to focus most of their time on
what do they think the future technology
will be and don't yet thinking about the
application year right sometimes we call
this speculative research why is I make
a good progress there always be a lot of
people who can think about how to apply
this technology to make money into it
you go for the real impact so we really
want the people to change the status quo
of technology not necessary to score off
the market share or number of user or
application we have plenty of the
business people and partner people to
think about that we want the researcher
to really thinking about how far they
can push technology how far they can
push the stay of VR and so this is why
we encourage people to take a risk and
we even go as far to tell and if you
think too much about technology most
likely you will make a two small step
and that's not good enough for research
because if the most thing we do are
incremental then I think do so to
afeared its purpose
[Music]
so earlier we talked about the AI winter
and the AI spring that some people are
saying as a result of a number of
factors in high tech that are all
converging at the same time talk a
little bit about this AI spring so I
think early on we mention even myself I
actually experienced two AI winter and
then now everyone can notice now AI is a
hot topic that no one can escape so this
is why some people called minority I
sprint but there are also people
particularly some research research were
worried is it too much hype and they're
too much expectation and then we might
not be able to deliver will cost another
AI winter so some people say maybe now
it's AI autumn but I think the that will
happen I think Michaels who use the
drywall called
digital transformation even though the
AI technology we have today still has
some limitation but this can do a lot
with so-called data-driven intelligence
and that will actually power a lot of
digital transformation for just about
everything we do in pcs everything we do
in life so that transformation is real
and it's happening it's already
happening for a couple years and will
actually continue at least for
foreseeable future so that's certain
very exciting in business by intensive
technology most AI today are the black
box you can solve know what pub but
cannot solve why problem this today is
the very hard problem we are to barely
scratch the surface
we haven't made even any significant
progress here but we need to continue
push the technology as a researcher I
use the war AI + H I so it's always the
Lea is help the human intelligence help
human to solve problems together so we
build AI system to actually help us to
solve and but the algorithm for us so
who is master it's very very clear and
of course we need to make sure all the
we are used to a in the highway now as
you use the AI to do any harmful stop so
that's really how I think about it I
like this idea that you just mentioned
the coevolution of human and machine
intelligence so could you talk a little
bit about why you think coevolution of
intelligence is an important thing to
address today yeah I do have a talk I
get particularly in China talking about
coevolution of AI and HR human
intelligence actually this is based on
my personal experience when I start the
AI 20 years ago I also think AI very
differently then today and the more
discovery making AI the more partners we
may I
they mean at the same time also
understand ourselves better myself
better my inheritance abated and I think
the human intelligence it's actually
built on creativity now real necessary
building I'll memorize a lot of data we
do see data we need to inspire by
looking at data but we cannot look at
lots of data or memorize a lot of data
so in a sense we invent computer to help
us to things we know how to do it so we
are free us to thinking of a hard
apartment to educate with the algorithm
for other harder part and we also
realize our creativity particular the
problem-solving not to mention the
wisdom I mean I don't think I'm
qualified to define wisdom let me give
people the wiser device I think that
also what the human so uniquely possess
if you ask me this question 10 years ago
I probably would not articulate that way
because I think the intelligence we used
to think that someone can memorize or
someone can compute very fast very
accurately think about the one founder
of the unit intelligence but today no
I'm trying to compete with the
calculator not even talk about computer
all memory right I already move for
three years I still have now remember my
home phone number so so I think the the
way we think about internet you really
change once we make a more discovery and
then the other PI also mentioned humans
internet you mostly not to do with big
data but with small data thinking about
Einstein a hundred plus
years ago he has no equipment to observe
he just hypothesis we don't know how he
I got and they're ain't 100 years later
we use the modern equipment we can
barely observe those wave you cannot
argue instead Sutton has no big data
probably has zero data right so just
like could creativity right a lot of
time you just come up with idea people
ask you where you come from you cannot
explain on the other hand today's AI is
all based on huge amount of data we
cannot come so much data but we can come
up with the algorithm led to the
computer to look through the data now a
lot of time even though still not enough
you still need to do your prediction and
guess and the creativity all combined
you actually can make the big pocket so
I think the coevolution there's another
aspect we should also feel lucky not
feel threatened we are the first
generation of the humankind we live
together with the AI something we
created right so we can use them as a
tool to help us to solve problem to
inspire us to think about poverty in a
new way also inspired to think about
ourselves differently the reason I'm so
optimistic is we are the master we
abandon and since it they are now real
life for I don't think theatre I don't
think there's a moral issue to say we
are the master well it's fascinating
because I you know you listen to the
popular press you listen to some of the
big sort of naysayer voices out there
that are we're doomed we've created our
demise and yet maybe they're looking at
it the wrong way and thinking about it
too largely and it's more like they say
here augment not replace the Machine has
no life we have the life right so this
is why if they're the machine would do
all this harmful thing I guarantee
there's a live phone designer behind a
human behind that machine has no life
and then no DNA right we had a DNA to
tell us we need to survive we need to
fight for our gene to continue so this
is why we
our kids we need to continue our gene
yeah
machine come on machines got programmed
by human like it's not it's a bio gene
turning they need to fight for survival
fight for we saw so I I mean this this
is why I think philosophically I'm not
saying there is no beta machine but the
source of pain machine got to be a human
behind a designer but human designer so
we better regulate the human but not
worried about the Machine yeah and maybe
it's not a bad designer but somebody who
designed for a good purpose and it got
taken on by somebody with bad intentions
but still people absolutely it's bad Oh
at the end all h of you two people it's
human right you are too many of our
listeners and inspiration especially
when it comes to your career in hi-tech
among your titles this corporate vice
president chairman distinguished
scientist managing director ie fellow
but you didn't start there much like
Microsoft Research Asia you started
small what was your path to where you
are today
yeah I think with that group for
whatever reason I just love math but at
the same time I also like application oh
you can say I like to see real war
impact so this is why looking bad it's
actually not surprised I end up here so
I got a double ye undergraduate degree
and I really like abstract math so I go
to start II computer scientist CMU got
my PhD after PhD typically well you got
the PhD you can go to academic I like
the academic but I also think I want to
see application I want to see the impact
and the impact that I decide well impact
mmm doing computer science
if I can see the technology can benefit
can be used by millions at that time I
think about millions today I ought to
think about periods right so this is why
I end up joining Microsoft and also
going back to your first question
Microsoft and research there's such
exciting thing I'm not just product I
don't think I would be happy just to
impart and not that you push the
technology and the law
explore all this future possibility
right so the combination of research and
then Prada Empire not directly in the
right because I'm not responsible for
power but if I see my technology whether
it's a computer vision of speech or
system technology be used by millions
billions people I think that I feel I
really do something tangible for
humankind so if I really look bad I
think to think why is it's not supplies
to end up here but second I also say I
need to be very simple micro so give me
such a wonderful opportunity for me to
fulfill not only my goal also give me a
job I actually find the funk to do
everyday and get up every morning
knowing I would explore this and that
and what try this and try that and then
the process itself a lot of time it's
enjoyable already so you don't already
not to mention if I can have a good
result along the way sounds like a
wonderful I shall went on thank you so
much for joining us today it's been
inspiring thank you
[Music]
to learn more about dr. Shaw one hon and
the latest innovations from ms are Asia
visit microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]